is it possible to have a stable peaceful
world with a good balance of power with
the where it's China and us as
superpowers you it's a bipolar world no
longer unipol yeah okay so you're
hypothesizing a world where they
dominate Asia yeah and we dominate the
Western Hemisphere I I believe there
would be uh a great deal of security
competition intense security competition
between those two superpowers the
definition of intense matters here so it
could be
small small military conflicts or it
could be extremely large unstable
military conflicts right well conflict
let's use the word War okay so I I
distinguish between security competition
and War and what I'm telling you is
you'll have an intense security
competition where there's no shooting or
if there's shooting it's mainly proxies
that are doing the fighting much like
the Vietnam War right uh or you could
have a case where one of those
superpowers was involved in a war
against a proxy of the other superpower
Korean War think the Korean War the
United States fought the Chinese who
were allied with the Soviets at the time
MH but uh a war between the United
States and China just like a war between
the United States and the Soviet Union
during the Cold War that's what you
really want to invoid avoid so I think
you'd have an intense security
competition right you'd have wars
involving proxies of each of those two
superpowers and you would probably have
some Wars where one of the superpowers
was involved in a proxy right with the
other super one of the super other
superpowers proxies so it seems likely
then if that's the case then it would be
Taiwan is the proxy and us fighting
China through the proxy of Taiwan
yeah well that would assume the United
States but you want to remember you're
hypothesizing a situation where China
dominates Asia oh already has dominated
yes it's already dominated Taiwan uh I
see we we well where do you find the
proxies well austr the Middle East could
be a good case oh wow Persian Gulf right
oh boy and then our discussion of Israel
becomes even more dramatically yeah well
Israel Israel gets involved I think I
think in this scenario if you're talking
about a us China competition right and
you're talking about the Middle East I
think it's the gulf it's it's the Saudis
the Iranians the Iraqis it's the oil
don't you think it could be Israel
versus Iran with
some very 1984 kind of dramatic
Partnership of Iran Russia and China
versus United States Europe and um
Israel I think that's possible yeah I
think that's possible yeah now that I I
mean I hadn't thought about it uh until
you said it but yeah I think that that
that is possible isn't isn't that
terrifying yeah well that you know in
your scenario where China already
dominates Asia and we dominate the
Western Hemisphere uh I think you start
talking about where are the most likely
places uh that the United States and
China go head-to-head uh or or fight
through proxies uh I I think it is the
goal for the Middle East and the
scenario that you
posit